consider the differential equation the
derivative of Y with respect to X is
equal to 2x minus y on the axes provided
sketch a slope field for the given
differential equation at the six points
indicated and we see one two three four
five six points and so what I can do is
let me set up a table actually let me
set up a table with three columns one
for X 1 for y and then one for the
derivative of Y with respect to X which
this differential equation tells us in
terms of x and y and so we can look at
the different points this point right
over here when X is 1 and Y is 2 X is 1
Y is 2 well the derivative they tell us
is 2 times X minus y so this is 2 X
minus y so it's going to be 2 times 1
minus 2 which is equal to 0 and so if
the derivative there is equal to 0 then
if I were to draw a line that indicates
the slope at that point well I would
draw a line with a 0 slope so it would
look it would look something like let me
draw it a little bit it would look
something like that alright let's keep
going
let's look at this point where X is
equal to 0 Y is equal to 2 X is equal to
0 Y is equal to 2 the derivative is
going to be 2 times X minus y so it's
going to be 0 minus 2 which is equal to
negative 2 so how do we draw a slope of
negative 2 well it's going to go from
the top left to the bottom right it's
going to be pretty steep so it might
look it might look something like that
that looks like a slope of negative let
me try to draw it a little bit a little
bit better so I could draw it well
that's pretty good
maybe I shouldn't use my line tool let
me just try to draw a reasonable so if I
have a slope of negative 2 as I move one
the right I move to down so it should
look something like something like that
alright let's keep going
x1 y1 X is 1 Y is 1 it's going to be 2
times 1 minus 1 so this is 2 minus 1
it's going to have a slope of 1 and so
that would look something like a slope
of 1
looks something like that or I can let
me just draw it like draw it by hand
that's actually easier and then we have
x is 0 Y is 1 x is 0 Y is 1 slope is
going to be 2 times 0 minus 1 which is
equal to negative 1 so now the slope is
negative 1 and just like that notice
it's less negative than up here it's
less steep
so it's and then let's go to X is 1 Y is
negative 1 X is 1 Y is negative 1 so
it's going to be 2 times 1 minus
negative 1 so this is 2 2 plus 1 this is
equal to positive 3 so here the slope
it's going to be even steeper but now in
the positive sense so the slope of 3
would look something like that and then
finally we have x is 0 Y is negative 1
it's going to be 2 times 0 minus
negative 1 which is going to be equal to
a slope of 1 which is going to look like
this it should be the same it should be
parallel to what we have right over
there
and we're done all right let's do Part B
now find the second derivative of Y with
respect to X in terms of X and y
determine the concavity of all solutions
for the given differential equation in
Quadrant two give a reason for your
answer all right so first let's just
find the second derivative so we already
know that dy let me give myself a little
bit more space actually we already know
that the derivative of Y with respect to
X is equal to 2x minus y now to find the
second derivative just want to take the
derivative of both sides of this with
respect to X so it's
do that so I could take the derivative
of the left-hand side with respect to X
and the derivative of the right-hand
side with respect to X and so what is
this going to be on the left-hand side
the notation just want would just be the
second derivative of Y with respect to X
and then over here let's take the
derivative of each of these with respect
to X the derivative of 2x with respect
to X is going to be equal to 2 and then
minus the derivative of Y with respect
to X was just going to be minus 2 2
minus the derivative of Y with respect
to X and so when so we can say okay we
found the second derivative but remember
they're saying in terms of x and y right
now I found the second derivative in
terms of well in terms of a constant and
in terms of the first derivative and so
we can substitute our expression for the
first derivative back here to have this
expression in terms of x and y and so
this is all going to be equal to let me
write it over here the second derivative
of Y with respect to X is going to be
equal to 2 minus well the derivative of
Y with respect to X we already know is
2x minus y 2x minus y and so this is
going to be equal to 2 minus 2x plus y
plus y and then they say determine the
concavity of all solutions for the given
differential equation in Quadrant two
remember if you're thinking about our
coordinate axes you think about our
coordinate axes so if that's our Y axis
that is our x axis this is quadrant one
this is quadrant two this is quadrant
three and this is quadrant 4 so they're
talking about quadrant two so what do we
know about X and y in quadrant two we
know X is less than 0 and we know Y is
greater than 0 so quadrant two let's
write like this quadrant quadrant two we
know X is less than 0 and Y is greater
than 0 and so if that is the case so if
we get
we have two minus two X plus y so this
is going to be this right over here it's
going to be greater than 0 and negative
2 times a negative value well this is
also going to be greater than 0 so
quadrant 2 because of this that means if
this is this whole expression is going
to be positive negative 2 times a
negative number is going to be positive
plus a positive plus a positive is going
to be positive so the second derivative
second derivative with respect to X is
positive positive which means that R
which means that our slope is increasing
over that interval which means that we
have positive we could say that we are
con concavity I always have trouble
saying that concavity concavity is
upwards upwards and if you ever forget
whether ok a second derivative being
positive is that concavity upwards or
downwards I always just like to draw
kind of our you know the canonical
concave upwards or concave downwards and
you can see here that your slope your
slope here is turning less negative or
you can say it's becoming it's becoming
more positive its increasing and it
continues to increase when you are
concave upwards so second derivative
positive you are concave upwards second
derivative negative you're going to be
concave downwards I'll get rid of this
because you wouldn't want to put that on
the actual AP test